[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport spécial
bilan de fin d'année dans ce magazine
nous reviendrons notamment sur les
moments forts qui ont marqué cette année
à 2017 et sur l'agenda sport 2018 c'est
parti à pour le sommaire handball coup
de projecteur aujourd'hui sur le club de
plaisir l'équipe senior a réussi une
superbe saison 2017 en montant en
nationale 3 et en terminant deuxième de
cette phase aller des performances qui
nous ont poussé à les désigner sportif
illinois de l'année à 2017
reportage à suivre pour aiguiller le sky
est lui aussi monté cette saison en
division honneur les joueurs affichent
pour le moment trois victoires au
compteur depuis le début de la saison
dont seconde en quelques instants le
coach et les joueurs pour débriefer
cette phase aller
golf dans notre rubrique agenda nous
parlons évidemment de la ryder cup le
rendez-vous sera organisée en septembre
2018 au golf national de saint quentin
en yvelines avec les meilleurs joueurs
du monde et plus de 60 mille spectateurs
sur les greens et détail dans ce
magazine coup de projecteur à présent
sur le mobile les bilans de cette
première partie à deux saisons
[Musique]
on commence donc ce magazine par notre
top 3 des sportifs illinois de l'année à
2017 en première position on retrouve le
club de plaisir l'équipe senior a réussi
un parcours presque parfait cette saison
en terminant premier du championnat de
prénationale et en finissant deuxième de
cette phase aller en menace de nationale
3 avec trois petits points du leader
un montage de à xavier jaglin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
2010cette année de la consécration pour
le plaisir handball club après avoir
lutté pour la montée pendant six ans les
plaisirs ont enfin validé leur ticket
pour la nationale 3 en mai dernier en
s'imposant contre draveil à domicile
l'équipe termine première du classement
avec une seule défaite au compteur
donc je pense que ça représente
énormément pour le public pour le club
les anciens du club le tout les
dirigeants les bénévoles les petits
c'est vraiment une grande famille c'est
pour tout le monde
voilà c'est pas que nous c'est pas que
les 12 c'est vraiment un club qui avait
tout ce moment là tous ensemble
après l'euphorie retour sur terre
plaisir se mesurer pour la première fois
une équipe de nationale 3 en coupe de
france début septembre après un match
serré les plaisirs oies sont finalement
éliminé par le club d'ici aux tirs au
but le score 28 à 27 une défaite
formatrice pour le groupe une équipe
réellement profil des équipes de
nationale 3 à savoir pas des joueurs
avec un petit peu tous les profils et
notamment des grands gabarits qui sont
capables d'aller jouer des duels et ces
choses qu'on trouve très peu en
prénationale donc voila c'était très
intéressant de cette équipe
avec voilà nos qualités aujourd'hui
après quatre mois de compétition plaisir
pointe à la deuxième place du
championnat de nationale 3 3 longueurs
du leader saint paulois et ziv ils ont
notamment réalisé une série de quatre
victoires consécutives entre octobre et
novembre
l'équipe a été remaniée puisque
effectivement on a perdu quelques
joueurs le fait de rappeler ces quelques
joueurs n'ont pas changé l'état d'esprit
du groupe
l'état d'esprit est toujours positif les
mecs s'entraîne sérieusement on
s'entraîne sérieusement et donc sa
deuxième place au championnat je pense
qu'elle est méritée
maintenant on sait que ça va être dur de
la garder ma nounou battre et continuer
sur cet état d'esprit qui est pour
l'instant est repproché avec cette bande
de potes
malgré cette place de dauphin l'objectif
annoncé de cette saison 2017-2018 reste
le maintien
la montée pour le moment une question
taboue écoutez je sais pas si on peut
parler de monter certains vous diront
peut-être que j'y pense
aujourd'hui déjà on prend chaque match
et le groupement chaque match l'un après
les autres avec l'objectif est
effectivement de les gagner
très belle année 2010 est et espérant
que l'année 2010 sera de même au bureau
les y reprendra officiellement la
compétition le 27 janvier prochain
l'extérieur contre chaville une victoire
et les plaisirs wa deviendraient encore
un peu plus l'équipe a su en 2018 dans
ce championnat à la deuxième place de
notre top trois on retrouve un boxeur
l'élan courtois a dit lahm ou m'a dit le
sportif a réussi une brillante année à
2017 en réussissant reconquérir la
ceinture de champion d'europe contre
l'espanyol mariano hilario en mai
dernier yvelinois de 36 ans ensuite
réussi à conserver son titre des poids
super-moyens en s'imposant aux points
contre le français christophe rey brasse
au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines on écoute adil
hamouma dit à la sortie de ce combat
d'europe
dans les yvelines grande fierté et
encore merci pour ceux qui me
soutiennent fierté un objectif de
terminer on est parti pour d'autres
objectifs encore le monde a dit la môme
a dit affiche aujourd'hui un bilan de 23
victoires dont 16 par ko 1 nul et 4
défaites depuis le début de sa carrière
pour l'instant la date de son prochain
combat n'est pas encore connue on
termine notre top 3 par une équipe qui a
fait vibrer à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
cette saison le sky rugby
cette année 2010 est a été
particulièrement réussie pour le club
avec une montée en division honneur et
un bon début de saison ponctué par trois
victoires pour nous parler de cette
phase aller nous recevons sur ce plateau
le président à guillaume payen et trois
joueurs mathieu rafaillac trois quarts
centre louis valente troisième ligne et
julien legastelois le demi de mêlée de
l'équipe bonsoir je disais président
super année 2010 est pour la très très
bonne année puisqu'on a enfin réussi à
concrétiser le travail c'est à dire pour
le groupe senior monter dans la division
supérieure donc on a été content c'était
au mois de mars déjà après ça passe vite
mais là on finissait hier les matches
aller et à division honneur donc et donc
oui c'est une bonne année 2010 est
puisqu'on a enfin enfin franchir un
palier pour pour l'équipe senior hier
patrick a vraiment été franchie cette
année en 2017
oui un palier l'objectif c'était c'était
la montée ça fait trois ans depuis que
les nouveaux coachs en rêvait que
l'objectif c'est la montée
les deux premières années pour des
des raisons x ou y on n'y est pas arrivé
et cette année c'est tariq c'était une
satisfaction particulière et puis de
finir obtenir le match de la montée à la
maison devant le public on a fait une
on a fait une grosse fête après c'était
une grosse satisfaction pour l'ensemble
du groupe qui l'a depuis depuis quelques
années un accord très grosse fête du
coup spécial alors vous étiez passé tout
près de la division honneur l'année
précédente
vous avez échoué à une victoire
finalement de cette montée en division
honneur
est ce que vous avez vraiment envie de
la voir cette année encore plus que les
autres années forcément ça nous booste
de de se dire qu'on est passé vraiment
proches surtout enfin avec saison qui
était vraiment à la limite d'être
parfaite et du coup pensé quand on l'a
pas eue on sait ce pont ce qu'on veut
encore plus
et ça nous a je pense encore plus motivé
pour l'année d'après et c'est peut-être
ça qui a fait la différence sur les
dents du match finalement il y avait je
le disais un seul match à gagner pour
accéder à cette division honneur
finalement ça vous a rendu peut-être
plus fort de l'avoir raté cette montée
cette saison là mais peut-être c'est ce
qu'on sait ce qu'on se dise que ça à se
dire qu'on était déçu du match il ya
déjà longtemps mais un match qu'on
tenait bien et qu'on avait perdu à tour
en toute fin de partie et et qui nous a
gâché une saison avec 100% de victoires
c'est à dire qu'on a perdu un match ils
s'aiment d'empêcher de monter
l'arrière on est monté avec trois
défaites voilà c'est les saisons c'est
comme ça on se dit qu'on a réussi à
consolider notre jeu
à tous progressé qu'on n'arrive plus
fort en heure cette saison qu'est-ce qui
a fait la différence selon vous en
promotion honneur
l'année dernière la détermination en vie
et fait que malgré les défaites on a
trouvé en avant toujours toujours à
chaque fois chaque fois toujours 3es
fait c'est ça l'année dernière trois
défaites et malgré trois défaites
on a fait ce qu'il fallait faire pour
pouvoir monter ça a été fait il fallait
y croire vraiment cette cette montée
tout au long de la saison comme on
disait trois défaites
il fallait y croire tout au long de la
saison se dire que le groupe avait le
potentiel c'est votre rôle aussi en tant
que président peut-être de les rappeler
ouais temps de président en tant
qu'entraîneur nous le potentiel on
savait qu'on l'avait déjà avant avant la
montée forcément et voilà potentiel
qu'on a dit ça on n'a pas dit grand
chose donc
donc on rafalé fallait réussir à acter
les choses sur le terrain et cette
saison là on a battu les équipes
concurrentes nous reste à les battre
donc c'est c'est eh bien pour pour finir
le boulot et puis passer à autre chose
parce que là c'est l' aventure continue
mais à prendre une autre ampleur avec
une division de plus voilà univers où
plus on regarde justement le résultat de
votre dernier match contre ministère
finance
on finit bien l'année voilà vous
finissez bien années pour enfin quelle
est la raison de cet échec sur cette
année match de magie ras djir
je pense que on est arrivés sur le match
on n'avait pas n'avait pas une compo une
composition d'équipé total on n'avait
pas 22 joueurs alignés et puis dans les
têtes dès le début du match on n'était
pas donc on appris en prince fera deux
essais en cinq six minutes
donc on est vite fait à 12 0
12 0 au bout de cinq minutes c'est donc
derrière on va dire qu'on a on a un peu
lâché tout est allé beaucoup plus et
beaucoup plus fort on s'attendait
peut-être pas forcément à une équipe de
ce niveau là et là on a pas on n'a pas
suivi on n'a pas mis les ingrédients
qu'il fallait en tout cas pas pendant 80
minutes et derrière le score est lourd
mais finalement assez représentatif de
la de la physionomie du match
du coup vous clôturez cette phase aller
avec un bilan de 3 victoires 1 nul et 6
défaites depuis septembre voilà le
niveau est vraiment y est vraiment
supérieure vraiment haut à l'année
précédente
on va dire que ce rapport à l'année
précédente ce qui change vraiment c'est
pas que on peut pas on n'a pas le droit
à l'erreur
toutes les erreurs aspects cachés
l'année dernière des horreurs qu'on
aurait pu faire peut-être cinq fois dans
le match bas vous l'aurez payé par un
essai cette année toutes celles qu'on
fait on le paye direct c'est ça sur le
match d'hier par exemple on se trouve
deux fois cinq minutes de jeu on a déjà
deux essais contre nous donc c'est vrai
que ça se fait beaucoup plus vite
vous vous étiez assez préparés à cette
pro à cette division honneur oui je
pense pourtant intéressant où elle a
tout fait pour préparer au maximum et y
être prêt au début de saison mais le
niveau c'est parce qu'on figure vous
êtes d'accord président on a nous l'idée
toujours pareil c'est de faire le
maximum
que tous fassent le maximum donc on
espère que passant en garde sous le pied
ça serait dommage parce que nous ont
tous vécu en tant qu'entraîneur on
essaie de trouver des solutions entre
charest dans la préparation revient tout
ça voilà dans la préparation dans la
préparation de saison la préparation des
matches on savait fort au maximum après
après on a toujours envie d'avoir plus
donc
donc oui effectivement pour que le bilan
de trois victoires c'est oublier ça au
match retour c'est de faire plus que
trois victoires donc va falloir force
accrochée à faire continuer à bosser et
ça après sur le terrain les joueurs ils
vont faire le boulot pour ce spot bien
vous êtes actuellement dans le milieu de
classement
cette poule est ce que vous pensez
pouvoir aller plus haut comment fut
comme enfin la même façon qu'on a
toujours fonctionné
c'est à dire que même quand on est en
promotion honneur avant et qu'on était
dans le haut du tableau voir dans tout
en haut du tableau
on prend les matches les uns après les
autres et on fait en sorte de se
concentrer sur la prestation
et si on est à 100% après on gagne on
perd c'est un détail mais on était
important qu'en mai c'est un détail dans
le sens où on est content ce qu'on a
fait parce qu'on a donnée maximum il
faut surtout pas de regret à la fin de
la saison et à la fin de chaque match si
on a des regrets c'est qu'on sait qu'on
l'entend et hier on a des regrets alors
perdu mais d'avoir fait une performance
aussi aussi petite voix dans
l'engagement dans les plaquages donc pas
dans des choses qu'on sur lesquels on
peut pas se louper gagner un match par
match c'est autre chose mais les choses
sur lesquelles on est pourquoi pas le
podium
non non c'est nous ont jamais très loin
et trop loin on a des réunions du
pouvoir déjà se trouver du podium mais
c'est pas si on a le podium l'année
d'après ça me va très bien merci à tous
les cas d'être passé sur ce plateau ou
souhaite le meilleur pour cette année à
2018 et surtout qu'elle soit aussi belle
que cette année 2010 est merci à tous
les cas lorsque si on continue à parler
de rugby et montigny-le-bretonneux promu
cette saison en promotion honneur vie
débuts contrastés depuis septembre les
inimités ans concédé cinq défaites la
dernière a été enregistré ce dimanche 17
décembre contre l'équipe du ce et l'oat
chesnaysiens 35 à 20 mai montigné
engrangé quatre victoires cette saison
des résultats qui leur permet d'occuper
la sixième place du classement à 12
points du premier relégable le maintien
objectif annoncé du club ne semble se
dessiner dieryck bien encore mais cette
fois ci en fédérale 2 plaisir promis
dans cette division termine la phase
aller du championnat la 10e place du
classement avec 11 points engrangés en
11 matchs disputés leur bilan neuf
victoires et deux défaites depuis
septembre dernier
pour l'instant les plaisirs oise sont
dans leurs objectifs ils avaient annoncé
le maintien en début de saison et pour
le coach sébastien ans cali l'équipe
progresse de match en match
on écoute on fait tous beaucoup plus
vite
les déplacements se font bien
l'organisation avance aussi la
communication entre se passe bien aussi
les derniers matches ont prouvé qu'on
était dans la vérité n'a pris de point
de bonus c'est une victoire sur les
quatre derniers matchs et ont très
franchement mérité mieux mais bon on est
encore en train d'apprendre et on
travaille un peu un bleu mans mais
j'espère vraiment faire une belle phase
retour prochain match pour plaisir le
dimanche 14 janvier sur le terrain à de
bobigny on continue par du handball
féminin montigny-le-bretonneux n'y
arrive pas dans le championnat de
nationale 2 les i montaigne qui visait
une place sur le podium en début de
saison sont actuellement dernière du
championnat après huit journées
disputées leur bilan aucune victoire
depuis septembre sept défaites et un
seul match nul c'était lors de la
première journée contre le paris
saint-germain
les filles de denis chalets sont déjà
distancés au classement le compte quatre
points de retard sur palaiseau prochain
match le 13 janvier prochain contre
aubervilliers à domicile en football la
saison s'annonce très longue pour
l'équipe senior de trappes sur le podium
depuis octobre les hommes d'arno est
mise y sont actuellement neuvièmes du
championnat de r4 après un match nul
contre epinay leur dernière rencontre de
cette année 2010 est les trappistes se
sont dans le ventre mou de cette poule c
avec 12 points engrangés depuis le début
de la saison le retour sur les terrains
est prévue le 14 janvier à domicile
contre plutôt faut pour faire pour
refermer cette page bilan de l'année
2010 elle je vous propose à présent de
remonter le temps pour revivre revivre
tous les meilleurs moments de sport qui
se sont déroulées pendant 12 mois dans
les îles
accrochez-vous ce voyage vous est
proposée par le nostalgique romain
respini
[Musique]
j'ai problème la fiche les biya minutes
sinon j'aurais déjà été évoquée plus
justement les est que j'attendais un peu
plus vite et j'ai connu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
râches point une grosse salle bonne
ambiance et je pense que c'est grâce à
50 ac
aujourd'hui on a réussi et franchement
on avait à coeur de bien faire ici sur
le stade vélodrome et montrer qu on
avait très belle salle à paris
[Musique]
hilali l'organisation d'une grande
compétition internationale au patrimoine
en étant au sein des écuries du château
de versailles
c'est
réussite exceptionnelle
[Musique]
je pense que ça représente énormément
pour le public pour le club les anciens
du club le tout les dirigeants les
bénévoles les petits c'est vraiment
vraiment une grande famille c'est pour
tout le monde
voilà c'est pas que nous c'est pas que
les bus et
un club tel est justement là tous
ensemble
[Musique]
une réaction de joie la soeur de joie
les jeux olympiques sont à paris en 2024
c'est officiellement officiel maintenant
et là c'est vraiment une explosion de
joie on a senti lors de l' annonce
c'est un parcours de golf fantastique et
d'être le capitaine de cette ryder cup
est vraiment spécial c'est une journée
incroyable avec tous ses enfants je suis
très excité à l'idée de vivre cette
ryder cup à paris
[Musique]
encore champion d'europe
zibeline grande fierté est encore bien
souvent ceux qui me soutiennent
tu es un objectif terminer on est parti
vers d'autres objectifs encore le monde
[Musique]
c'est quand même une première au niveau
national c'est le top
on ne peut pas monter plus aujourd'hui
et donc qu'on a c'est un honneur d'une
part et puis on est ravis d'accueillir
toute la france pour le beau département
des yvelines
[Musique]
et
on se propulse donc en appuyant sur les
pédales à l'avant ici le problème
regardez le problème est là pour la
précision de la conduite difficultés que
c'est ça faut pas mettre la roue dans
les trous et il offre un très important
le fin c'est juste et petit corps on
tourner le guidon comme ça pour tirer
sur la corde et le patin aussi freiner
bloquent la route de temps voilà ça
bloque la revoilà voilà le principe
[Musique]
on passe maintenant à l'agenda sport de
l'année à 2018
[Musique]
on commence cet agenda par l'événement
sport qu'il ne faudra pas manquer dans
les yvelines en 2018 la ryder cup la
plus prestigieuse compétition de golf au
monde sera organisée sur le parcours de
l'albatros du golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines rénové il y a
deux ans pour l'occasion elle opposera
du 28 au 30 septembre les meilleurs
golfeurs américains aux meilleurs
joueurs hors pair devant plus de 60000
spectateurs et plus de 750 millions de
téléspectateurs à travers le monde parmi
les supporters on devrait apercevoir de
nombreux français dans les tribunes on
écoute pascal grizot le président de la
commission ryder cup 2018 sur les 51
mille billets qui étaient mis en vente
par jour tout a été vendu en moins d'une
heure et demie et il n'y a plus de 27000
personnes qui sont sur une liste
d'attenté
il y aura au moins 45 % de français à
peu près puisque 40% des billets étaient
réservées aux français et qu'en plus
quand les français ont participé dans
les achats internationaux il encore cinq
français 5 % de français supplémentaires
qui ont réussi à acheter des billets
dont 45 % de français
c'est un chiffre extrêmement important
dernier ryder cup ce soit aux états unis
ou en europe il devait y avoir 250
français
donc là on va passer un chiffre beaucoup
plus impressionnant le golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueillera
également l'open de france de golf avec
des têtes d'affiché européennes et
mondiales au mois de juillet à prochain
nous allons maintenant parler de
handball féminin dans cet agenda après
avoir accueilli un match de championnant
2016 entre issy paris brest le vélodrome
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines va
accueillir le 3 février prochain une
rencontre de coupe d'europe
ici paris affrontera l'équipe
norvégienne de vie spurs kristiansand au
4ème tour de la compétition ce sera donc
le deuxième rendez vous organisé au
vélodrome par les dirigeants parisiens
pour lui parler à deux ce match nous
recevons sur ce plateau l'organisateur
local patrick chiab hugues jarreau le
directeur général du vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et le
responsable communication d'ici paris
baptiste mallet bonsoir charmant son
poids à devoir
avez vous voulu retenter l'expérience
vélodrome bâtisse et ben on est très
content parce que tout d'abord
la première édition a été un succès on
peut le dire n'est plus de 5400
personnes qui sont venus au vélodrome
pour pourvoir du handball c'était le
premier événement
le sport collectif avec une mise en
place qui a demandé beaucoup
d'organisation et à une résultat au bout
il ya même eu le succès sportif donc on
est tombé d'accord avec le vélodrome
pour rééditer l'opération
et cette fois ci ça va être en coupe
d'europe donc avec encore plus de
spectacle on l'espère patrick châble ce
n'est pas n'importe quel match c'est un
quatrième tour de coupe d'europe et lui
contre des norvégiennes réputée très
difficile à battre
on monte d'un cran véritablement par
rapport au premier match qu'elle s'y est
très bien comme ça ça plus que assurer
la fréquentation on espère toujours
optimale et puis et puis bon de monter
en gamme et donc c'est très bien pour
d'avoir deux du handball de ce niveau
sur saint quentin et pourquoi le choix
s'est porté sur cette équipe norvégienne
justement baptiste alors il ya tout
d'abord une question de calendrier
on a eu le tirage des phases de poules
il ya environ 2 3 semaines et il se
trouve que la date la plus proche pour
qu'on avait plus ou moins anticipée pour
jouer au vélodrome c'était contre contre
l'équipe des vipers l'équipe norvégienne
est d'ailleurs quand on voit l'actualité
d'hier soir ça tombe plutôt bien
rééditer le france norvège plus vos
clubs
justement ça vous aide encore plus haut
niveau la promotion de l'événement bien
sûr déjà on est très content très
content pour l'équipe de france est très
content aussi pour nos joueuses
notamment norvégienne hollandaise où
mène et j'en passe qui ont participé à
ce mondial est forcément un match
diffusé donc je parle du masi hier soir
diffusé sur tf1 donc de handball féminin
c'est très rare et il se peut que nous
que nous que nous apporter du plus en
terme de notoriété
le test l'année dernière contre brest
finalement s'est avéré positif
justement c'était l'objectif de passer
un cran d'aller un peu au dessus encore
un peu plus c'est vrai que le résultat
de la précédente édition était
surprenant puisqu'on s'attendait pas
quinze jours avant à avoir fait le plein
de l'enceinte
et puis bah quand on connaît un succès
on aime bien connaître un deuxième
donc moi je trouve ça très bien pour la
pour les 58 voix de voir du handball de
très haut niveau
une jarre ô vous qui êtes le responsable
du verdon de saint quentin en yvelines
c'est positif de voir du handball dans
le vélodrome comprends tout à fait mais
c'est clair qu'on s'inscrit contre
enfin dans dans le programme du
vélodrome initiale c'est à dire c'est un
vélodrome entraînements l'équipe de
france mais au-delà de ça on a une
obligation multisports donc le
c'est le premier élément qui avait lancé
c'est en fait c'était le handball on a
aussi eu précédemment dernier au circuit
du comment du judo et on a continué à en
faire d'accueil de la boxe plein de
choses et quand ils avaient fait le test
la dernière avec le hand on avait un peu
de doute sur savoir s'il réussira pas
remplies a déjà tous complètement le
vélodrome c'était un vrai succès donc
aujourd'hui on s'engage dans la durée
avec issy paris pour conclure un
partenariat et faire en sorte qu'ils
puissent venir autant qu'il veut ça
s'inscrit complètement dans la démarche
d'avoir des salles grande qu'on puisse
pour accueillir ce type d'événement fait
dans paris on en manque d'idées qui va
être construite pour les jo nous en
attendant on est tout à fait dans ce
registre hier donc il faut pas hésiter
d'autres sports peuvent venir on peut
les accueillir et la preuve c'est que le
rang des revenus donc il n'y a pas
d'incompatibilité écrivez nous en tout
cas les jeux sont vraiment ravi de
revenir au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines on écoute les
réactions des joueuses sur ce match est
comme ça va être très sympa
l'année dernière nous avons vu contre
brest et c'était génial de jouer au
vélodrome
il y avait beaucoup de monde et une très
bonne ambiance c'était une belle
expérience
ce match est spécial pour moi parce que
je vais jouer contre une équipe de mon
pays j'ai joué avec certaines rejouer
poutrelle dans différentes équipes
c'est une super idée parce que ça permet
aussi d'aller chercher un peu public
ailleurs et voilà de les fidéliser
al club par contre c'est vrai que c'est
un peu compliqué pour les je suis
habitué à jouer à domicile
voilà mais bon moi je trouve que si on
arrive à gagner du public après si on
arrive à les fidéliser et qui viennent
nous voir au palais des sports d'issy
les moulineaux à la suite ça peut être
vraiment une bonne idée
il y aura également une joueuse d'issy
paris qui jouera à domicile c'est
victoria alric la gardienne de 20 ans
d'ici paris donc qui a joué à voisin
retenu pendant deux ans et à montigny le
bretonneux pendant trois ans elle est
évidemment ravi de revenir dans sa ville
on les coûte cher parce je voir les
copains les copines mais oui ça reste le
premier club important donc ça compte
on sait que les supporters de 50 ans
sont sympas chaleureux il met du bruit
donc il ya moins que ça met une grosse
ambiance
ça permet aussi ce type d'histoire une
délocalisation comme celle là patrick
szewe vous la connaissez bien à victoria
bah oui c'est elle a fait quant à elle
est passée à montigny a fait du match
superbe
elle n'avait pas 17 ans qu'elle ait joué
les gens en équipe en nationale 2 quoi
c'était c'est vraiment la fin une fin de
saison mémorable et bombe suivi son
parcours mais j'espère pour elle qu'elle
ira très loin
baptiste dernière question ça coûte
combien tout simplement pour revenir au
vélodrome c'est accessible à tous oui on
est parti
sur les mêmes tarifs que l'édition
précédente
donc sachant qu'on fait des tarifs
dégressifs pour des clubs les organismes
qui veulent venir au plus grand nombre
donc
dans donné que ça a bien marché la
saison dernière on aurait dit les mêmes
tarifs et la billetterie est ouverte de
8 à 12 euros à peu près même un peu
moins pas moins bien mais ici à des
packs un sou de 10 euros 3 euros
bon en tout cas le message est passé
merci à tous les trois années passées
sur ce plateau et bonne chance pour
organiser ce grand événement au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
c'est la fin de ce statut de sport merci
d'avoir su on se retrouve le lundi à 8
janvier pour un nouveau numéro
passer d'excellentes fêtes de fin
d'année à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]